so
so
uh
[Music]
happy super bowl sunday everybody that's
right you just tapped into the squad
ride presented by draftkings live in the
bleacher report app and it is finally
here
the big game the championship greg
everybody knows we're gonna do a big for
super bowl sunday what do you got in
store for the people of the comment
section today
connor it is super bowl sunday and i am
feeling
very very
generous i've got custom odds boosts
from our friends over at draftkings
hoodies of course we're giving away
jerseys connors
those dk dollars are back yes those dk
dollars are back and i'm giving away an
iphone at the end of the show
but the producer just whispered into my
ear give away 250 of those dk dollars
right now so connor i am in the handy
dandy ipad to the people that are new to
the show this right here is how you get
your hoodies
i'm in here connor and i see
i see maxwell rexella in the comments
shout out to you maxo rexel saying he's
rocking with the bengals i also see
uh
i i see
mtm01 said the bengals are going to win
so let's see if there if if
if it's true
they're right most of the time i don't
know why i had a trouble reading that
but anyway mt you were walking away with
250 dk dollars connor let's get this
thing going
yeah let's get it rolling the comment
section is going to be jumping today for
super bowl sunday and if all of that
isn't enough greg's giving out the
hoodies dk dollars we got the iphone
giveaway at the end if that's not enough
be sure to check out draftkings for a
chance to win a million dollar free bet
yeah this is insane right here
draftkings has given out up to 10
million dollars in three bets this week
often by 2 p.m eastern today that means
you got a couple hours so you can hang
around here and do it after the show and
you can win a free bet of anywhere from
ten dollars to a million dollars check
out draftkings.com for official rules
buddy now that is a deal so you gotta
get on draftkings and get it done all
right you guys know how we do things
around here this is the show where we
are looking for anytime touchdown
scorers we want your locks of the week
and it's chosen by you the squad that's
why this is called the squad right
before we get started let's take a look
at some of our favorite moments from the
season from our lock legends
yo guys what do you like for any time
touchdown this
weekend guy's crispy when it's doing
from vegas is the lock of the century it
is happening this very weekend
[Music]
who's doing it for us this week come on
buddy
buttercup's gonna give us a lot but he's
coming back with the green balls looking
like super tough entire week the sun god
let's go you guys have got to see what i
just pulled in
count on him to rumble in for at least
one this week ride with the squad and
cash your tickets
[Applause]
right we asked you on social
we asked you in the app greg you know
what it is we want your anytime
touchdown scores
let's look at the most popular picks
that were sent to us cooper cup at the
top minus 190 cam makers not that far
behind along with joe mixon the ground
game is some of the favorites here then
it's time for the plus money legends
jamar chase odell beckham very happy
being in los angeles t higgins a long
shot at plus 175 and then the super long
shots as the backup running backs for
los angeles and sony michelle and
henderson activated off the ir so
that being said
we have four legendary picks to show you
the last one standing is the squad ride
leader of super bowl sunday they take
home the title they take home the jersey
greg's gonna boost the odds and then
we're all going to bet on that player to
score so let's waste no time right here
we got matt od 28 let's see the
selection for super bowl sunday matt
what's going on fellas we're here to
pick the
anytime touchdown score in the super
bowl this year we got harley she's going
to pick it out for us all right guy
who you got
let's see
t higgins plus 175 lock it in
harley rolling with t higgins coming in
at plus 175 we got our first challenger
of the day in evan j
d
let's see the up
welcome to lock city they were deciding
anytime touchdown score with the coin
flip whatever it lands on is who we're
going with and whatever side of the coin
is we're going for coin tosses sunday
let's get it
looks like it's joe mixing for this
sunday let's go and tails
a who day match up to kick things off we
got t higgins we got joe mixon joe mixon
looking as more of a favorite minus 105.
t higgins coming in as a little bit of
an underdog at plus 175. so greg
let him know what you need in the
comment section and do you like any of
these in our first matchup of the day
i need everybody and i mean everybody to
get in the comments and let us know if
you're rocking with t higgins or if
you're rocking with joe mixon
connor i'll hop in here this t higgins
pick is actually kind of interesting
it's actually kind of interesting my man
ocho cinco said it best like death and
texas 85
is always open and my man t higgins is
number 85 for those bengals so uh uh
this one it interests it interests me
but the joe mixon pick
i think i want to lean that way connor
because in order for the bengals to win
joe mixon has to get going in this game
he has to be a big factor in this game
if the bengals want to win so uh i'm
gonna lean this way which way are you
rocking with connor
i'm gonna roll with t higgins and i know
it's more of the long shot play here but
the rams are just not allowing anything
against them on the ground right now
they haven't you know surrendered more
than 61 yards in a playoff game on the
ground this year and yeah maybe the
bengals get into the red maybe the
bengals get into the you know a goal
line situation and they are going to
force feed mixing but
i think they're going to be playing from
behind and i think that's going to mean
they're throwing and i think that means
they're going to have to look at someone
besides jamar chase a lot so i like the
t higgins pick where the comments going
right now are they with t higgins or do
they like the favorite and joe mixon on
the ground
connor i silva 33 has a t higgins gif
he's flexing
uh shout out to you i silva underscore
33 you are walking away with the hoodie
also trigger way trigger way has the
same gift
t higgins flexing
shout out to you trick away you're
walking with a hoodie wattages wada just
has the same gift hey they're gifting it
up in the comments with the t higgins
gif of him flexing so shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned you all
are walking away with hoodies connor
i just said his name three times in a
row man
i just said his name three times in a
row
actually
actually hold on they want me to go back
to the comments and the next one the
next one i choose i'm gonna just rock
with it because i i kind of want joe
mixing i'm i'm throwing some little you
know i might be throwing some
yeah anyway here we go
bam connor connor
don't say i fixed it
but my man j colston 11. he has a joe
mixing gift and i landed on it so jay
colton 11 you're walking away with
hoodie but joe mixon is moving on not t
higgins joe mixon is moving on to the
next round
the coin flip legend joe mixon at the
buzzer moving on to round two let's see
what he's got in store in terms of a
challenger big mike boy making his way
in let's see the selection here from big
mike
hey there br nation here i have some of
the top players here to score in any
time at td in the super bowl weekend
play a little cubs good ball see if you
can help us figure out which one
riding with jamar chase anytime td lock
him in
all right buckets from big mike going
with jamar chase so we got another who
day match up with this bengals offense
we had the wide receiver two in t
higgins against joe mixon in round one
now we got the wide receiver won in
jamar chase and he's still coming in at
plus money here though greg
is this enough uh is this enough for you
to knock down your boy joe mixon or
are you leaning are you still rolling
with mixing and where are the people
going because they made a late surge in
the last round to get mixing it around
too
they did make a late surge but uh conor
i'm kind of torn on this one i'll be
honest
both of these guys in order for the
bengals to win both of these guys need
to have games so i i'm torn on which
side to lean you know we got the plus
money that's very tempting with jamar
chase and you guys know what we can do
here on the squad ride and then we have
joe mixon and
connor i mean connor's talking about
what the rams defense does to the
running game or what they have been
doing to the running game in the
playoffs so i'm i'm i'm torn here connor
i'ma lean on the comments which way are
you leaning i like jamar chase it goes
back to the t higgins argument i think
the bengals are going to have to throw
the ball and i think they're going to
have to throw often especially in the
second half when there's a little bit
more urgency i think that's what stands
out to me so i like jamar chase i think
they got to get him involved in in every
way possible vertically short game
screens uh pitch passes reverses
whatever it's going to take you got to
get the ball of jamar chase's hand and
greg let's be real the the plus money is
the cherry on top here are the comments
rolling with me on this one
hey i feel you i feel you connor
sometimes the value is what draws you
and i got my man kp giants talk the take
the money plus value connor look it told
you value talks
joe to jamar he has jamar he has jamar
chase uh doing the gritty in the
comments i also see
uh rahul n air 24 raul
in air 24 has a jamar chase gif of him
scoring a touchdown i also see daniel
brown jamar chase is flexing
uh as a gift uh that's it connor that's
it that's it shout out to everybody okay
br fan 1351 also has a jamar chase
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with hoodie connor
there's no curveball this one the
producer is not talking to me about this
one i'm not jumping back into the
comments it's it's it's clear
cut my man jamar chase is moving on to
the next round
all right jamar chase there with a
little bit of an upset over joe mixon
but he's got one more round in order to
be our squad rod leader for super bowl
sunday are we going to get any rams
touchdown scorers on this show i'm
starting to wonder final round ray white
and blue coming in hot let's see the
pick
have any picks on who will score a
touchdown in the super bowl
um
odell odell
all right quick with the thinking
they're going with o'dell so we got a
match up of two top flight wide
receivers jamar chase ah just been
phenomenal this year odell
revitalized in los angeles both plus
money here greg both plus money yeah do
you like one better than the other this
feels like a nice play on either side
it does feel like a nice play connor but
uh
i like the rams in this game so i think
i'm gonna rock with odell
in the plus 120 i mean when the lights
come on when it's a big time game my man
odell beckham shows up so i think it's
the super bowl it's the biggest game of
the year i think he's gonna have to show
up he's gonna get one touchdown so uh
i'm rocking with odell and the plus
money connor which way are you leaning
i'm with you i love odell to score in
this game and we'll talk about that
later at a very popular later segment
i think odell is ready to go for the
super bowl and as much as cooper cup is
a superstar they're going to throw
enough where o'dell is going to have his
and o'dell might have the better
matchups in the red zone so
i'm with you greg that it's if you're
rolling with the rams you also roll with
their touchdown scores and as great as
jamar chase has been this year i just
feel more confident in almost anybody
suiting up for the rams passing game
that's heavily involved in the game plan
so
that being said though it's not up to
you it's not up to me it's up to the
comments are they going to roll with
odell are they going to roll with a
little bit more of a favorite here in
jamar chase
let me see let me see okay i see a drake
sighting i see a drake sighting in the
comments uh wada just says drake with
all the money on odell drake did put a
lot of money on odell shout out to you
wattages i gave you a hoodie earlier but
appreciate you in the comments uh i got
i got
drew barnett he gave me an odell gift
odell was at the ufc event uh shout out
to you drew barnett you're walking away
with a hoodie i also see
um
snoop uh shark charcoal three three nine
says chase over o'dell we don't even
need to know if ob obj is playing yet
his wife is in labor wow i don't know if
that's true but if his wife is in labor
congratulations odell uh
the next one i choose
connor we're just gonna rock with it
next one i choose is gonna rock with
okay oh no his his username is oh no
he's rocking with jamar chase so
therefore
connor
jamar chase
big mike boy
is the winner of this week's and the
last squad ride of the year uh so shout
out to you my man big mike boy i am
sending you a hoodie but let me pull up
the graphics so i can show you guys
something
you guys see jamar chase plus 100 watch
this magic poof there it is it just
changed from plus 100 to plus 125. shout
out to our friends over at draftkings
for boosting it up uh
connor
jamar chase
we are all riding brother
jamar chase coming in at plus 125 thanks
to greg and shout out to big mike boy
you are taking home the title of the
squad rod leader and the nfl jersey of
your choice pretty sweet deal pretty big
win and that boost isn't enough we got
another special one for you and it has
to do with our boy jamar chase once
again and you see it right here the odds
to get over three and a half rushing
yards have been boosted from minus 130
to plus 120. that is a mega shift right
here he's just got to go over three and
a half rushing yards
jamar chase has had i think five carries
in these playoffs so far so you just
need one carry for four plus yards
you're good to go pretty great boost
right there so take advantage of the
dark horse boost brought to you by br
betting greg let's talk about this game
right we're looking at the touchdown
scores last segment let's talk about who
who's going to win the game let's look
at the major market bets for this big
game and don't forget to get on
draftkings because if you are a
first-time customer you can place a
money line bet of five dollars and you
can win 280
in additional free bets along with your
actual cash winnings so that is uh
that's quite the haul i would say here
greg a pretty sweet deal but let him
know right now what we got going on as
we look at the super bowl matchup
me and my man connor is going to go
through this matchup and we're going to
give you guys our favorite major market
picks so get in those comments fill them
up and tell us what you think i'm giving
away hoodies and i'm also
giving away a jersey this segment connor
all right let's look at the board here
greg we got rams bengals it's the super
bowl we are looking at a rams team that
is favored by four and a half and now at
four that line has been consistently
shifting around a little bit in the last
48 hours nothing substantial a point
total of 48 and a half which is
traditionally pretty high for a
postseason game and of course there are
the money line favorites at -190 not
insane odds to be honest with you here
so
i'll kick things off here and i'm
curious if you agree i like the rams in
this game i think the rams cover i think
they can win by two field goals i'm not
afraid of that the money line is very
very safe to me and it's rare to use the
word safe with a super bowl winner or a
super bowl bet
and then you look at the point total i'm
gonna go under i think these teams just
feel each other out too early in the
game where nobody wants to throw the
first haymaker we have to wait the
second half to that so you should look
at your first half point total i think
it was around 24 and a half the last
time i looked at it go under the overall
point total a little bit more risky if i
had to go i go under but my biggest
takeaway here is greg the rams are a
veteran-filled team sean mcveigh has
been a head coach in this spot zach
taylor on the other side he was the rams
quarterback coach when they were in the
super bowl it's a little bit different
quarterback coach compared to head coach
the rams will be ready to go and take
this home what are you thinking with
this super bowl
yeah connor i took a deep breath because
this one's hard for me to say
as a 49er fan but
hey i like money connor i like money so
i got to be a realist i am rocking with
the los angeles rams moneyline yes i
have that bed in already
now i this one mike can get ugly connor
it might can get ugly i i really don't
see the bengals uh maybe they might win
but i don't see them winning but
i just want to talk about that spread
the reason i'm saying this because i
want to look at the spread spreads minus
four i can see them winning by touchdown
wanna buy two touchdowns it might get
ugly out there connor so
take the spread take the money line i'm
rocking with the money line the over
under connor
to be honest
i lean over i lean over i think the
offenses is gonna be out there putting
on the show uh so i think that's the
only one that we disagree with but
we're rocking with the rams i think that
one's the easy bet of the super bowl
i'm with you as well and now looking
at this board right now i want to know
what the comments are saying and i think
you got a dk dollar surprise for
somebody in that comment section looking
to throw down some money on this game
grumpy 808 says burro has the eye of the
tiger in the year of the tiger
cigar party tonight for the bengals my
man grumpy 808 said that there he is
right there on your screen shout out to
you also
officially ronald my man greg was good
bet on the bengals bro i'm telling you
bengals win 35-28 let me get that jersey
shout out to you officially ronald
landon rams all day
shout out to you landon
uh
here we go
here we go you see oh no right there
that's too bad greg's losing money
tonight
hold on let me get him back on the
screen
there he is oh no that's too bad greg's
losing money tonight connor you see
that's bad vibes the guys just throw bad
vibes at me but that but listen but
listen connor when we get bad vibes on
this show we turn bad vibes into good
vibes so oh no you threw bad vibes at me
but i'm throwing good vibes at you you
are walking away with 250 dk dollars i
hope you don't lose this 250 dk dollars
i actually hope you turn this into a
parlay and win with this 250 dk dollars
but there you go my friend oh no
all right oh no taking home the 250 dk
dollars
it's going to be interesting probably
going to bed at all the bengals we'll
see how that goes all right shout out to
all the commenters don't forget to get
on draftkings and take advantage of the
five dollars to win 280 dollars when you
lock your money line bet this weekend
all right looking at one of our favorite
times of the show it's prop lock or drop
it
listen this is the time of the show
where we take a look at the player props
everybody loves doing that for the super
bowl we've been doing it all year we're
looking at these over under so greg let
him know what we got and kick off our
first prop of today's show
i need everybody to get in the comments
and let me know if you like the prop if
you don't like it if you think it's a
lock if you're dropping it just fill
those comments up with takes
and connor let's get to the first one
it's yummy jamar chase to have over or
under
74 and a half receiving yards conor
i'mma start it off i don't think my man
is gonna get this i'm rocking with the
the rams in this game i mentioned it
earlier it might can get nasty uh their
offense might be stalling off to start
the game
now connor i do want to mention maybe
just maybe
he might get this in garbage time
as they're trying to catch up from being
behind
but
i'll put my money on the under so i'm
rocking with the under connor which way
are you leaning
i'm going with the under as well i love
jamar chase but i don't like this
matchup for him right you have to see
jalen ramsey across from you probably
majority of the game he might be the
best pure cover corner in the entire nfl
he's got to be ready to go
and when you look at raheem morris the
defensive coordinator for the rams when
you come into this game you have two op
you know goals here pressure joe burrow
because their offensive line stinks and
bracket take away jamar chase and make
him throw to somebody else anybody else
i like t higgins there's no doubt about
that but is he good enough to take over
this game that remains to be seen so
74.5 yards it's a lot he's got a brutal
match up he's going against a really
smart defensive coordinator i think he
gets his don't think he gets to this
marker all right let's look on the other
side here greg and look at cooper cup
the wide receiver for the rams that has
just been remarkable this year the best
player in fantasy football ppr
a bigger number right we went chase 74
and a half cup 99 and a half here
i'm not afraid to go over this mark at
all when you look at the bengals the way
they style their coverage it's going to
be different from the rams the rams can
come into this game and go jaylen ramsey
you're on chase and if we have to give a
safety help we will with cupping the
rams against that bengals defense they
can paper cut them just continue to
paper cut them up a catch here for 12 a
catch here for seven cup can come out of
this game with nine to a you know ten
catches for 120 to 130 yards i don't
fear the over are you with me on that
connor i am right there with you uh i
got a little scouting report from my
friend chad ocho cinco he told me that
the bengals like to come out and zone
defense and i'm here
to tell you right now if the bengals
come out and zone defense my man cooper
cup is gonna have an absolute field day
so look for that adjustment look for
that adjustment in the game bingo's come
out and zone might switch it over to man
if my man cooper cup is dialing them up
in the zone because that's that's what
he does connor he he he fills out those
soft spots in the zone and he sits there
and stafford feeds him the ball he's his
comfort blanket so
um
i can see this going over easily connor
it surprises me that it's only 99 and a
half i know this is a super bowl but
like bro we were just going over cooper
cup reception yards that were in the
hundreds like not not even four weeks
ago three weeks ago so this one
surprises me but uh yeah i am taking the
over connor but let's move on to the to
the quarterbacks now the guys that are
putting the ball in the air we got joe
burrow to throw for over or under
279
and a half yards connor we've been on
this same trend we we've both been
talking about the rams and we've both
been talking about the bengals and
we think the ram is going to win we
don't think the bengals is going to win
so with that being just the the map that
adds up to me is is under it's just the
under in this matchup for joe burrow i
think this is going to be a tough task
for him against that rams defense
talk to me connor
do you like him over here or do you like
the under i like the under i think this
is a lot of yards this is 280 yards he's
only done this once out of the three
playoff games he's been in this year as
much as we love joe burrow joe burrow is
going to be a superstar in this league
for a very very long time especially
thrown in jamar chase and t higgins but
this is a big mark and i just don't
trust the bengals in this game enough
even if they go down and they go into
throw every down mode yeah that sounds
great for garbage time yards but then
you have aaron donald and von miller
pinning their ears back and getting a
full go to get up field and rush the
quarterback they don't have to contain
the run anymore so then what is he going
to do
joe burrows ran away from good defenders
this year right we know jeffrey simmons
on the titans had a field day against
that bengals offensive line and they
still won the game
this is different this is aaron donald
maybe the best defensive player of the
nfl the last decade and von miller a guy
that's won a super bowl mvp so
i just can't trust this number here greg
it's way too high i could see him
getting a 250 260. you know that's kind
of more what he's hovered around the two
out of three playoff games now
let's look on the other side matt
stafford also coming in at a really
really big number 274.5 so almost the
same over under total here for matthew
stafford and his prop for passing yards
here i don't fear this one as much
because one i think the rams can control
this game
and two even if the rams go up early
they're not going to hand the ball to
cam akers and sony michelle three times
in a row and then punt back to the
bengals you don't do that in the super
bowl you need to keep your foot on the
gas you need to run up the score in
order to make sure you don't have a
falcons 28-3 episode all over again
nobody wants to beat that guy ever again
so matt stafford i think he comes down
goes 3 50 and four no that's just
ridiculous but can he get to 280 290
maybe even hover around 300 i think he
can
i think he can too connor i absolutely
think he can uh
matthew stafford might be the biggest
story of this super bowl we know what he
went through in detroit and this is his
first year in la and hey he's in the
super bowl with this rams team so uh
275 yards 274 and a half
i think my guy can go get that rams i
think they put on the show today and uh
in the win
i can see my guy stafford throwing for
275 and also connor i'm putting it out
there
going to go get that mvp trophy so uh
i'm rocking with my man matthew stafford
going over in the
throwing yards
all right so greg and i see eye to eye
on all four props which means i think we
got something special in store for super
bowl sunday
it's same game parlay time that's right
let's put this all together make it a
parlay look at all four picks to kick
things off we had jamar chase going
under for his receiving yards we had
cooper cup going over joe burrow going
under matt stafford going over plus 6.75
and even better greg thanks to our
friends at draftkings right now this is
risk free if you want to trail us and
make it all you have to do is opt in
to a risk-free same game parlay up to 10
so if you trail us and this loses which
it won't you will get your ten dollars
back and if you do put in when it wins
you can win big those are plus 675 over
there so i'm loving this greg we are in
the giving spirit draftkings is in the
giving spirit which kind of kind of
reminds me i think you still have an nfl
jersey to give away before we move on
here
connor i do have a jersey to give away s
young 37
they said connor is correct with the
exclamation mark there it is
and conor is correct he's correct about
uh his picks and he's also correct that
i needed to give out a jersey so connor
you are correct and therefore s young
you are walking away with a jersey of
your choice so shout out to you
all right so
you got the jersey to give away
and you're not done greg you still got
the 250 dk dollars and we're not gonna
give away that iphone yet let's not get
crazy but we're talking parlays and that
means we're talking dk dollars so what
do you got
connor you know i'm always down for
giveaways bro i'm always down for a
giveaway but i need everybody to get in
the comments and let me know if you're
riding
me and connor's parlay or not uh
i'm giving away 250 dk dollars i'm
giving away 250 dk dollars and i still
got that iphone
so connor
let's get to it man let's let's let's
get to it
all right let's keep it moving community
comments contest time
we asked you this week who is going to
be the first player to score a touchdown
earlier in the show we just want your
touchdown locks now we want to know
who's going to be the first touchdown
scorer cooper cup the favorite at plus
500 along with the two running backs and
joe mixon and cam akers at plus 750.
then it gets interesting you have jamar
chase at plus 800. you have odell
beckham at plus 900 followed by t
higgins and the rams back up running
backs and darrell henderson and sony
michelle at plus 1600
so
those are the odds for first touchdown
score pretty juicy you can walk away
with a big one and i'll sneak one more
in there that i threw a little money on
kendall blanton coming in at plus 1300
tyler higbee out for this game blanton
will start at tight end but greg i think
you've got some good comments sent your
way so let's take a look at what we got
in store from the comment section
yes sir my man big mike 13 hit us up in
the comments connor and he said cooper
cup first touchdown
stafford's gonna find him for a long
yard touchdown bingo secondary cannot
stop him ways they can't
but uh connor i actually like this one i
like this one a lot we have a segment
coming up and uh there's a reason i like
this one i'll just tell you guys that
there's a reason i like this one but i
like this one a lot connor which what's
your spill on this do you like this one
or are you not feeling it
i mean you can't hate on big mike here
yeah it's the favorite but it's still
plus 500 and maybe you know sometimes
the favorite is the smart pick right so
for cooper cup uh nobody would be
surprised if he comes out with the big
play early and they show that they're
not afraid to target their top guy no
matter what the defense is throwing at
him so big mike
they
i'm sorry to cut you off bro but they
come out in that zone remember i said
that they come out in that zone so big
mike might be on to something connor big
mike might be on to something but i also
also got hit up connor
by it's me man no not me it's not me but
his username is it's me man his name is
john and its comment is he says i think
bengals are really going to be ready to
play mixing run in the first one collect
your money here folks because i'm not a
betting man
this one's very interesting he wants me
to put my money down on joe mixon and
then he tells me he's not a betting man
connor
i don't think i'm rocking with this one
you mentioned that rams defense in the
playoffs and then my guy's not a betting
man anyone i i'm cool off this one
how are you feeling about it
yeah john's out here giving lock some
pics but i don't know if he believes in
it himself enough to bet but we'll still
we'll still give him some love we'll
still give him some shine i'm not
rocking with this one greg i don't i
don't like joe mixon in this game i
don't like the bengals rush offense in
this game uh maybe we'll be surprised
maybe the trend bucks the other way and
the rams finally give up some rushing
yards for the first time in this
postseason but i like the cooper cup
pick better to be honest with you
yeah i like the cooper cup pick better
so with that being said my man big mike
i am sending you
a hoodie
of your choice but connor let me hop
into these comments because i got to see
what the people are talking about um i
see
mkent93 says obj first score touchdown
is a lot plus 900. shout out to you m
kent you're walking away with a jersey
no no with the hoodie i'm sorry and then
i also see
officially cut officially cut i'm
thinking the joe mix and first td they
got established to run the game early
winners only appreciate you for the
winners only love and i agree connor i
do agree with what my man just said he
said that they have to establish the run
early in order for the bengals to win
this game
they they're going to have to run the
ball
so i mean i like what he said he's
getting the hoodie uh but let's move on
connor let's move on to these bonus bets
man
yeah let's get into it this is our
favorite time of the show before we give
away that iphone greg and i are gonna
throw down our boldest bets for super
bowl sunday so greg let them know what
they need to do in the comments to get
involved in the giveaway action here
i need everybody and i mean everybody to
get in the comments and let me know if
you're rocking with me or if you're
rocking with my boy connor and our
boldest bets
giving away hoodies and also giving away
a jersey so connor let's get right to it
brother
what are you all right let's get back in
let's get back in on that same game
parlay action to kick things off i said
it earlier i love odell beckham to score
in this game unless he has to run out at
halftime uh to see the birth of his
child which would be quite the game
changer on a lot of betting tickets i
like odell beckham to score a touchdown
here
that odds those odds have moved it feels
like a little bit since this has been
placed buying up the point total and
going under 52 and a half and then cap
things off with a very simple pick in
our eyes greg rams win the game plus
390. you need a no dell touchdown you
just need to avoid a mega shootout and
you need the rams to not even cover just
win the game plus 390 what are you
rolling with
it's not a bad bet right there connor i
actually kind of like that one but uh
i'm rocking with something a little
unique connor and a little different i
got joe burl or matthew stafford to
throw a 50-yard touchdown pass connor
this is the super bowl
they're going to be taking big shots
they're going to be taking big shots in
the big game i just need one of them to
connect connor i just need one to
connect so i'm rocking with joe burrow
and i'm rocking with mast average just
throw one you got receivers all over the
field
plus 200 give it to me connor and that's
what i'm taking to the bank man so uh
let me see what these comments is
talking about let me see what these
comments is talking about
because i'm giving away hoodies and i'm
also giving away a jersey uh i see blitz
4 says i like that parlay from connor
shout out to you blitz 4 you are walking
away with the hoodie because i like that
parlay from connor as well uh i also see
i also see uh
ronald ronald's in there gotta go with
my man greg winners only appreciate you
ronald the comments just jumped i had
somebody else uh sharko sharko339
says no 50 yard td pass connor you know
what we do to bad vibes we turn bad
vibes in the good vibes so sharko you
are walking away with the hoodie
and i gotta give away this jersey
counter i gotta give the way this jersey
you see the wolf of broad street says
connor kid obj anytime touchdown a lock
rams control the game
shout out to the wolf of broad street
you
are walking away
with the jersey appreciate
man walking away with the jersey and now
it's time for someone to walk away with
this iphone greg's been holding on to it
the whole show once again another iphone
giveaway
this one's simple folks we're looking to
know who is going to win the super bowl
we're not asking you for a prop we're
not asking you for a touchdown lock we
just want to know who is going to win
the game the rams at minus 190 the
bengals at plus 160. these are the odds
greg let them know what they got to do
if they want to take home this brand new
iphone
i need you guys to get in the comments
and tell me your lot to win the super
bowl we're going to spin the wheel and
if your comment matches the team that is
chosen
you could win an iphone
all right all right so you heard from us
earlier greg and i are rocking with the
rams we like the rams money line in this
game
bengals can pull off the upset greg and
i are rolling with the rams we want the
comment section to jump off are you
rolling with the bengals are you rolling
with the rams and the wheel the old
faithful wheel
is gonna make the pick we have no
control over it well let's get this
thing spinning right now and make a pick
and if your pick
matches the wheels pick in the comments
you could be taking home the brand new
iphone all right let's keep it rolling
right here rams bengals rams bengals is
slowing up
it's slowing up and it just sneaks in on
the rams there that was
real close especially with that little
tilt back there at the end
greg you got to get into these comments
right now and give away this iphone
a lot of pressure giving away this
iphone connor
but i'm in the comments i'm in the
comments and i see
jojo473454 says i know y'all are rocking
with the rams but i still want that
bengals upset shout out to you jojo
uh you're walking away with a hoodie i'm
looking for a good comment
okay so here we go
here we
go i see
parker p hendrickson easy rams win me
and connor both said that earlier in the
show even if the line has moved up to
minus six and high six and a half connor
said it they might win by a touchdown so
let's make this money connor my man has
been listening parker has been listening
to us so therefore
parker you are walking away with the
iphone 13 so uh
hey shout out to you parker man turn up
and go ram part day only taking it home
that's right go rams parker taking home
the new iphone love the take
that's a wrap greg that's a wrap
congrats to the winners if you took home
a hoodie a jersey dk dollars or if
you're parker you took home the iphone
uh thank you to the commenters the
comment section jumping off is what
makes this show special it's what made
this show so special all year from when
we were back in august making picks on
futures with akeeb talib and vince young
or if you rode with us every single
sunday greg and i were on all the way to
super bowl sunday
get in on draftkings there's custom
boosts there's promos five to win 280.
uh jamar chase boosted jamarche's
darkhorse rush prop at plus 120 just
needs four yards
same game parlay promo risk-free you
could trail me and greg's prop picks at
plus 675 throw 10 bucks on it if it
loses which it won't you get your ten
dollars back
all right everyone thank you for sending
your reaction videos thank you to the
lock legends shout out to all the squad
ride leaders
all season long for one last time i'm
connor rogers joined as always by my man
greg ivory
we'll see you again
[Music]